hello everybody this is Peter Cooper
from the NCBI service desk and welcome
to another NCBI webinar this is one of
our shorter ones the ones we call the
NCBI minutes so we'll be talking for
about ten minutes here to some reminders
and that's what this slide is for that
the recording of this webinar will be
available on our YouTube channel let me
take us about a week to ten days to get
that up there the materials which
basically are some backup slides between
kind of screenshots we're going to show
you today are available on our FTP site
and compressed URL there will take you
to those materials so today Melissa
landrum who is the lead developer for
the clinvar resources is going to be
talking about the new clinvar submission
wizard and I'm going to turn it over to
Melissa right now thanks Peter hello
everyone thanks for joining us today
clinvar is the ncbi database for
archiving interpretations of variants
relative to diseases and other
phenotypes all interpretations in
clinvar are provided by our submitters
namely clinical testing labs research
labs resources like mm Jane reviews and
locus-specific databases as well as
expert panels and practice guidelines a
link to information on how to submit to
clinvar is available from the clinvar
homepage submitters who have several
interpretations to submit or submitters
that submit repeatedly like clinical
testing labs use our submission
spreadsheet templates and there's a
section here on this page with
information about those templates for
researchers and other submitters who
submit a single variant at a time it may
be easier to use the clinvar submission
wizard to guide you through the
submission process for example a genetic
counselor may review a variant and a lab
report and want to submit her own
interpretation to clinvar or a research
lab may be publishing a paper on a new
causative variant for disease to get to
the wizard from this page you can click
on how to submit and you'll see a link
here to ncbi's variation submission
portal so we'll click on that also note
that you can get to the submission
portal from ncbi's home page for this
demo today I'm
going to switch to an internal site but
note that when you use the submission
portal you will not need to make any
changes to the URL when you first login
to the variation submission portal
you'll need to register your
organization you can use this help link
at the top of the page if you need more
information to do that once your
organization is registered and approved
on this page you'll see the name of your
organization so here from my demo my
organization name is clinvar submission
test lab and that will be followed by
two buttons one is for the clinvar
single submission wizard and the second
is to upload a new file submission like
a spreadsheet so today we're going to
click on the button for the submission
wizard the wizard walks you through a
series of tabs for different kinds of
information the first tab is for general
information about your submission here
you'll provide a name for the submission
which is just for your own use in
submission portal you can use the name
that's provided or you can give your own
name so today I'm going to submit a
variant that causes CFC syndrome so I'm
going to name my submission CFC one
variant one if your submission is part
of a named study like the caesar project
or the Framingham study you can provide
the name and a description of that study
in these boxes if your submission is
from a standalone research project you
can just leave these boxes blank you can
let us know if you need your submission
held until the corresponding paper is
published by selecting hold until
published here for this example I'm
going to select public so that my
submission is not held if the citation
is already available you can provide
that information in this section so
today for my demo I'm going to provide a
publication using a PubMed ID note that
on each tab your work is not saved until
you click the save and continue' button
but that does mean that you can start a
submission save your work for one or
more tabs and come back to the form
later to complete the process so I'll
click
save and continue and that takes us to
the next tab where you can indicate
which organizations should get
attribution for the submission if your
submission is from a single organization
like a single research lab you can
select single organization here and save
immediately the organization for which
you have logged on will be used
automatically if your submission is from
multiple groups each of those groups
needs to be registered and approved in
the submission portal first and you will
need to have been defined as a submitter
for each organization then when you
select multiple organizations all of
those groups are available in this table
1 should be specified as the primary
organization for the clinvar submission
and any number of others can be
specified as additional organizations
for today's example I'm going to submit
from a single organization use the next
tab to define the variant that you've
interpreted the interpreted variant may
be a single variant like a single
nucleotide substitution to single
variants as a compound heterozygote or
multiple variants insists as a haplotype
to describe the location and of the
variant and the change that you observed
you can use either HCBS nomenclature or
chromosome coordinates here called
sequence location when you select the
type of variant and method of
description the page updates to provide
the appropriate fields for you to fill
in for this example I'm submitting a
single variant in the b-raf gene so I'm
going to describe with an HTTPS
expression so I will fill in the
reference sequence with accession and
version a description of the sequence
change so that would be say the C dot or
g dot portion of an HTTPS expression I'm
going to fill in the gene note that you
can start typing the gene symbol and
you'll get a list from which to choose
I'm also going to provide an alternate
designation here this is the protein
name but this could be any other name by
which that variant is known including
other nucleotide descriptions with
legacy numbering systems there are other
optional fields to fill in you could
provide a variation identifier like a DB
snip RS number you can tell us the
location of the variance or the intron
or X on that it's in your local
identifier for the variant if you have a
database or the functional consequence
note that most of these fields on this
tab are optional so you can just fill in
the information that you have variants
in clinvar are generally interpreted
with respect to a disease or condition
so this condition is indicated on the
conditions tab if you have information
to submit unobserved phenotypes or
clinical features please wait to submit
them on the observations tab the
condition for which you are interpreting
the variant can be described with a
database identifiers like an om number
or you can provide the name of the
disease in this box in some cases a
variant is submitted to describe its
effect on a person's response to a drug
so for these cases you can select drug
response here and the page updates to
let you enter the drug name and
optionally the condition for which that
drug is used for this example I'm going
to submit on a disease CFC 1 syndrome
and I'm going to do so with an ohm
number use this tab to describe your
interpretation of the clinical
significance of the variant you must
provide a value for the clinical
significance and the options for that
are available in this pulldown menu so
I'm going to submit that this variant is
likely pathogenic and then optionally
you can also provide other information
such as the mode of inheritance for that
variant again options are provided in a
menu you can provide the date that the
clinical significance of that variant
was last evaluated and you can also
provide a comment that describes why you
classified the variant as you did this
tab also lets you provide information
about the method that you use to
classify variants which in clinvar we
call your assertion criteria
more information about this is available
on the clinvar website using this link
but in short this is a document that
describes the categories that you use to
classify variants such as benign
uncertain and pathogenic and the
criteria that you require to assign a
variant to each category if this
information is in your publication
describing the variant the PubMed ID can
be provided as the assertion criteria
here we do encourage submission of
assertion criteria if it is available
because it affects the review status or
number of stars on the resulting clinvar
record but it is not required so you can
certainly submit your data to clinvar
without assertion criteria leaving this
section blank clinvar submissions also
include the evidence that supports the
interpretation in the form of
observations of the variant those
observations may be described as
aggregates individuals or experimental
results at least one observation is
required per submission if you want to
submit data for many individuals as a
group you can use the aggregate section
you can submit information about more
than one group as distinct aggregates
for example if you had information from
a case control study you could complete
a section for the cases and another for
the controls in other words all of the
information in this observation applies
to everyone in this group
if you prefer you can provide
information about each individual with
the variant so in this case all of the
information is specific to that person
such as that person's age their
ethnicity or the phenotypes that were
observed in that individual for research
groups who have performed functional
assays to evaluate a variant that
experimental evidence can also be
described that information might include
the cell line used in the experiment or
the tissue type that was analyzed and
you can also provide a comment that
describes the results of your experiment
more structured details about the
experimental methods can also be
provided for this example I'm going to
submit one aggregate observation so this
is information about a group of affected
individuals with this disease so I'm
going to name my observation going to
indicate yes that they were affected
with the disease I'm going to indicate
that the allele origin was germline this
variant was detected as a germline
variant and I'm going to indicate that
this data was collected with clinical
testing I'm also going to indicate that
this was seen in a mixed group of males
and females the age range for these
individuals is from 1 to 20 years and
I'm going to indicate that i saw this
variant in six families and a total of
six single heterozygotes when you've
entered your information make sure to
click Save and continue and when you've
entered all of your observations click
Save and continue which takes you to the
final tab this is an overview of the
information that you've provided you can
take this opportunity to review the data
and go back and correct anything if
necessary once you're finished click the
submit button at the bottom of the page
this is a critical step this sends your
data to clinvar and sends you an email
confirming that you've submitted your
data when we receive the submission one
of the clinvar curators will check it
and contact you if there are any
questions about the data
otherwise your data will be promptly
processed and made available on the
clinvar website we encourage you to try
the clinvar submission wizard and we
welcome your feedback you can use the
contact link at the top of this page to
send us any questions or suggestions
about the wizard so if we have time for
a few questions if anyone wants to send
those in we'd be happy to answer them so
the first question that we have is how
do i know if i should use the wizard or
use a spreadsheet to submit to clinvar
so our recommendation is if you're
submitting a very small number of
variants at a time let's say less than
five it will probably be useful to use
the wizard if you're submitting more
variants let's say more than five or ten
variants it you will probably get faster
processing of your submission if you use
the spreadsheet because that makes it in
a more efficient process for our curator
to review many variants at a time and
get back to you with any issues so that
you can be processed more quickly the
second question we have here is if I
find that I've made a mistake in my
submission can I get into edit it so if
you have already sent your submission
into clinvar so here in the table you
can track the progress of your
submission so this is the one I just
entered and you can see the status is
submitted and it does not have an edit
button here so once you've already sent
it to clinvar it is not available to
edit if one of our curators find
something that needs to be fixed we will
change the status so that there is an
edit button here available for you to
fix your data if you have not yet
submitted your your wizard submission
you will see an edit button here and you
can go in and make any edits until
you're ready to submit so we have
another question should people only use
the wizard for submissions where they
have made their own assertion on the
variant or would clinicians use this to
report assertions directly from lab
reports so you can certainly use it to
submit your own assertion of the variant
so whether or not clinicians can use it
to report directly from lab reports you
actually for that I would actually
suggest at this point that if you want
would like to do that you can use the
spreadsheet and the reason is that the
lab themselves may have already
submitted that interpretation to clinvar
and if you are going to submit somebody
else's assertion we need to know who the
testing laboratory was so that is a
feature that we will add to the wizard
in a future release but for now that
information can be submitted on the
spreadsheet so if you would like to
submit that kind of information and you
need help with the spreadsheet please do
feel free to contact us ok this is Peter
Cooper I'm back again thanks Melissa
that was great that's all we have time
for today so we'll have the slides
materials that sort of and show you
those screenshots available on our
webinar some courses page and we'll have
this recording up on our YouTube channel
probably within a week or ten days
thanks everybody for coming i'm going to
go ahead and the webinar
you